As another hint, I will take the same matrix, matrix A
and take its determinant again but I will do it using a different technique, either technique is valid
so here we saying what is the determinant of
the 3X3 Matrix A and we can is we can rewrite first two column
so first column right over here we could rewrite it as 4 4 -2 and then the second column right over here
we could rewrite it
-1 5 0
and we could do is we could take the sum of the products
of the first three top left bottom left diagonal,
let me show you
so the product of that
that
plus
trying my best to draw this neatly
and then from that subtract
top right to bottom left diagonal
so from that subtract
let get a color
I havent used
subtract that
and that
sounds really confusing with all the diagonals
i have drawn
lets look at the blue ones first
4 times 5 times 0
plus -1 times 3 times -2
let me put these in parenthesis
plus 1 times 4 times 0
and then we gonna subtract all of these orange
diagonal, we go from the top right to the bottom left
so we gonna subtract
we could do 1 times 5 times -2
1 times 5 times -2 and then we can subtract
subtract 4 times 3 times 0
4 times 3 times 0
and then we can subtract
-1 times 4 times 0
and now we just evaluate this over here
4 times 5 times 0
is just 0
-1 times 3 times -2
is +6 so this is +6
1 times 4 times 0 is 0 once again
and then we have
1 times 5 times -2
is -10 but we have this negative out here so it becomes a +10
then 4 times 3 times , well thats just going to be 0.
and then we have -1 times 4 times 0, which is just 0
so we are left with +6 + 10
which is equal to +16